[Applaudissements]
une région en pleine expansion et riches
en votes
monsieur autour du chemin à faire d'un
4e nadel didier le 2,05 que les banlieue
de toronto ou une forteresse que les
conservateurs veulent reconquérir pour
avoir du succès dans les grands centres
urbains
il faut être progressiste paul demers et
d'un conseiller y militants
conservateurs depuis plus de vingt ans
il n'a jamais vu un chef conservateur
devenir premier ministre
sans remporter la bataille du grand
toronto monsieur harper avait fait des
gros gains à l'intérieur du 9,05 surtout
du côté des immigrants et puis monsieur
autour je pense doit se prendre d'âge de
7 de ses stratégies nos une fois en fout
djabi incontournable des fat l'a fait de
la radio depuis plus de vingt ans il
prend le pouls des électeurs en banlieue
de toronto
tropicana autour de la question du jour
qui est rennes ou toulouse
c'est du sang neuf à la tête du parti
l'ancien auditeur un des rares durant
l'émission à connaître le nouveau chef
conservateur où tout est encore un
inconnu par ici dit l'animateur notre
communauté aime les vedettes qui peuvent
épaté mais ce n'est pas son cas est née
d'un coup franc donné samedi au caire
[Musique]
d'ailleurs ajoute-t-il c'est
l'adversaire d'arnaud tour piqûres mais
qui qui a remporté le plus de voix dans
la grande région de toronto lors de la
course à la direction
beaucoup de sensibilisation à ces kids h
f
et puis monsieur autour astra se faire
connaître
pour ce militant conservateur et un menu
tout ne traîne pas le même vous les
quais d'ouchy absolument absolument jeu
ce vis-à-vis et monsieur autour pour le
bagage on va dire de le côté social
il rappelle qu'un oui nous tous dits pro
choix et qu'il promet de marché dans lé
défilé de la fierté gaie démontre aux
gens qu'il est ouvert que c'est pas une
question politique auquel il va se
pencher ces les réalités d'aujourd'hui
un changement de cap qui réjouit cet
avocat la victoire des lotos absolument
possible d' angie tiller joual etienne
aimerait bien devenir candidat pour le
parti conservateur qu'il croit
maintenant plus rassembleur donc si on
n'a pas le vote féminin on n'a pas le
vote des milléniaux on ne peut pas vote
banlieusards il nous reste quoi comme
vote
cependant même les fervents
conservateurs comme lui sont conscients
que la conquête du 9,05 sera semé
d'embûches avec une course électorale
qui est peut-être à nos portes et
renault 12 n'a pas de temps à perdre
pour courtiser les banlieusards je suis
sans emploi depuis le début de la
pandémie dit il la politique mais
portent plus pour le moment
les libéraux ont bien géré la crise
affirme ce banquier les promesses de
rennes aux tours d'équilibrer le budget
en disant c'est irresponsable
et puis il y à l'environnement le sujet
qui talonne les conservateurs mais qui
inquiètent plus paul demers
les gens parlent beaucoup de
l'environnement mais rarement ce qu'on
voit que leur décision et fait un peu ce
que pense aussi à l'étude elle a appuyé
d'oxford
même s'il était contre la taxe carbone
elle vote bleu au provincial et au
fédéral c'est différent elle ne veut pas
avoir le même parti à ottawa qu'à
queen's park afin de conserver un
certain équilibre stratégique
un pied à gauche et l'autre à droite dit
elle c'est la seule façon de ne pas
tourner en rond une réalité politique
dans la grande région de toronto à
laquelle arnaud tour devra rapidement
s'adapter